[Music]  hi everybody i'm lauren zima on bachelor  in paradise season 4 episode 3 we saw a  very flirtatious side of Dean yes Dean  was all about Kristina and newcomer  Danielle but with xeam being mean that's  the question the ladies did not like the  way that he was seemingly leading them  both on I don't know who Dean thinks he  is at this point and the reason this was  also interesting is that Dean has been  kind of a frontrunner to be the bachelor  so the way he behaves on bachelor in  paradise could turn the tide of fandom  one way or the other so what do you guys  think is Dean still your choice for  bachelor how do you think he'll do on  the rest of Paradise let me know over on  Twitter  you